Speaker 1: A Candice Owens has been refused
a covid test because the operator of an
independent covid testing clinic said you're
not getting a test here because you've been a
purveyor of covid disinformation. And immediately,
Candice Owens says, is this woman racist? Now,
why is this interesting? This is interesting
because Candice Owens has been a very popular
voice on the right as a black conservative,
supposedly. You know, it actually seems
this all might be a character, a grift to make
money. But let's let's imagine that it's real.
And Candice Owens has been a loud voice saying
all of this stuff about systemic racism,
all of this stuff about the right being
racist. The real problem, she has said
over the years is that the left so quickly goes
to assuming anything they don't like is racist.
I'm going to play a video for you here in which
Candace Owens immediately says maybe the woman
denying Mia covid test is racist. OK, so she's
doing it. Before getting into that, I want to
mention there's been a small controversy over the
last few days with Candice Owens, where she had
to cancel an event because she was suddenly ill,
but has been insisting that it's not coronavirus.
And yet here she is talking about how she's
actually been seeking a coronavirus test,
which obviously raises questions about why if
you definitely don't have the virus, why are you
getting tested for the virus? But she was denied
a covid test. We will look at why in a moment.
And here she is immediately saying maybe the
woman denying me the test is racist. I thought,
CANDIS, we weren't supposed to immediately say
the motivation must be racism for something
that we don't like. Take a look
Speaker 6: at this thing. Maybe
Corvin's racist. Maybe Susanna's racist. I'm
freaking out. I don't know the last time.
Speaker 1: Susana is the
woman who denied her the test.
Speaker 6: A Democrat refused a black person.
Services said this because I don't like
your thoughts and ideas. We were in the Jim Crow
era, but here we are and we're actually in Aspen,
Colorado. And Susanna, rationale that she
will Google you. This virus is not political,
but she's Googling people that are
signing up for tests to make sure
that their politics align with Susanna's.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine? Like, yeah,
well, OK. So dear God. So so the the the
argument here that Candace is making is
it's conceivable that I was denied a covid test
because Susanna is racist. Now, here's the email
that was sent from Susanna to Candace. Subject
appointment cancelation notice. I've just learned
of this testing request. And as the owner of this
business, I'm going to refuse this booking and
deny service. Whoa, wait a second. Isn't this what
conservatives want a business owner to decide? Who
do I want to serve and who don't I want to serve?
Susanna wrote, We cannot support anyone who is
proactively work to make this pandemic worse
by spreading misinformation, politicizing and
discouraging the wearing of masks and actively
dissuading people from receiving lifesaving
vaccinations. Candice Owens has done all that.
That's accurate. The only other local testing
option is the free kiosks by city hall, they
mail their tests to Texas and have inconsistent
result. Times do not take appointments, so it's
walking only midday weekdays in their back alley.
My team and myself have worked overtime to
exhaustion, unpaid and underpaid this last year,
spending our own capital to ensure our community
remains protective. It would be unfair to them
and to the sacrifices we have all made this year
to serve you, Susanna. That is the free market
of ideas that Candace owns, supposedly supports.
And it is a business owner deciding what is best
for themselves. And even though Candice
Owens has made money for years and years
saying, look at all these Democrats immediately
finding racism, the racism is seeing the racism.
And yet in the first five seconds, she says
maybe Susanna herself is racist. What a pathetic
hypocrite. And remember, it's almost certainly all
a grift. We'll have more on this on our Instagram
Findus there at David Pakman show.
Find me on Instagram at David Pakman